les bars du québec aimerait pouvoir
vendre de l'alcool pour emporter c'est
l'une des revendications de la nouvelle
association des bars du québec qui
compte une centaine de membres qui ont
choisi d'unir leurs forces
simone chevalot et la propriétaire de la
buvette chez simone et duferco à
montréal bonsoir on sort alors pour
courtois
je suis copropriétaire jeudi je suis un
pourri de formidable ça ceci autant sur
ok la buvette
pourquoi vous avez créé avec d'autres
gens là cette nouvelle association
écoutez je pense que c'est pierre
thibault d'abord je dois mentionner son
nom qui est propriétaire la taverne
saint sacrement morjan qui a pris
l'initiative dès le début de la crise
dès le début des champs matures des
restaurants et des bars de créer une
page en fait qui s'appelle un bar et une
pme parce que suite aux annonces
gouvernementales
il s'est rendu compte que les bars ne
faisait pas partie était pas un cul dans
cette pendant six heures
gouvernementales et il voulu alerter la
population de 2-7-1 conduite et si
aujourd'hui parce que nous sommes un
grand vecteur de l'économie ou québec et
nous avons notre place comme entreprise
en tout cas moi je demande cette place
comme je suis élu je suis entouré de
ceux ci nous sommes des gens rigoureux
professionnel sérieux et on a construit
une nouvelle façon de faire de
restauration depuis presqu'une vingtaine
d'années on n'est pas des restaurants on
est petit café des barres et on réclame
d'être considéré un part entière connaît
ce sont les restaurants parce que des
restaurants peuvent vendre des repas
pour emporter peuvent aller livrer des
repas et peuvent également dans certains
cas vendre s'ils ont les permis de
l'alcool avec les repas mais vous vous
ne pouvez pas vendre d'alcool vous
pouvez pas vendre
et présentement enchaînant les
restaurants peuvent vendre
en tous les cas ils ont le droit de
vendre du vin avec un repas pour
emporter nous au début de nos débuts de
la crise nous n'avions ni le droit de
vendre des repas pour emporter ni le
droit devant de la coupe du vin de la
bière du sud comme le fournil restaurant
est là maintenant mon la mesure est
assouplie nous pouvons rendre de la
nourriture mais pas de 20 à
l'avertissement nous sommes un bar à vin
on a une une cave uncam rempli de vin de
belles bouteilles qui ont été choisis
par notre super semaine hier jeudi il ya
tout un travail derrière seuls les
clients viennent nous voir parce que ils
veulent profiter de cette expertise là
de cette expérience et lens moment mais
on peut pas là ils vont échapper
en fait ces conditions ont permis de bar
alors que les restaurants n'ont qu'un
permis de l'amap lac ce qui bloque c'est
qu'on a permis d'abord d'avoir un poids
mais de par ses amis auprès de la régie
des alcools et des jeux du québec etc où
je suis j'ose dire que ça nous confère
un statut d' endroit peut-être c'est ce
qui nous manque que c'est ce que je
présume un endroit malfamé puis honteux
pour nous pourquoi vous rendre à madère
mais parce qu'il ya toujours une
réticence de la part de l'état a aidé
des bars non c'est tout simplement
l'impression que les lois ont peu suivi
l'évolution de la restauration nous et
je veux dire à la vie j'ai de ce fait
douze ans qu'on existe on est en été un
des premiers à ce en à se présenter
comme un paravent avec un permis oui la
map pack parce qu'on voulait offrir la
nourriture en voulait aussi à l'image de
ce qui se faisait déjà en espagne ou en
italie ont roulé que les gens puissent
arriver en et crois que là ça soit
boiron
20 et oui peut-être mangé avec des amis
on voit ce partout en italie et en
espagne les familles sont là quelle que
soit l'heure c'est en toute convivialité
en toute simplicité mais sait on
retrouvait déterminant d'avoir
interminables pour pouvoir s'exprimer
comme on souhaitait tout en étant
rigoureux dans notre offre de nourriture
donnée en ce moment donc il faut quoi il
faut dépoussiérer les lois il faut
dépoussiérer les loin monsieur fillion
mon dieu sait ce qu'il faut faire sortir
son plumeau qui ben ouais verruckt et
oui allait soulever allez vous alliez
ajouté mais n'est ce pas ce qu en fait
faut savoir que la marge de profit sur
la nourriture elle est minime
elle est d'environ 5% la marge de profit
sur et d'autant plus dans un endroit
comme la buvette chez simone où on a
toujours voulu être un endroit abordable
on met toujours voulu être un endroit
convivial aborde donc la marge est
encore plus petit
la marge de profit sur l'alcool sur le
vin elle est d'environ peut-être 12%
donc si on se marre ont de la nourriture
pour emporter sans sans levain qui sont
l'alcool il nous resterait rien parce
qu'en plus ce qu'il faut il faut en
rendre découle est bon et des tongs tous
les outils font en ronde des poules est
souvent pour 1000 $ de le poulet il va
nous rester quoi on peut payer des frais
fixes avec sonos consentants urgent de
points
on veut survivre payer des frais fixes
il est urgent d'intervenir beaucoup de
barons fermé vous parfait il est très
urgent il est vraiment urgent c'est de
toute urgence parce qu'on s'entend que
on sait pas qu'on va réouvrir et dans
quelles conditions pour une plus je veux
dire on se mentir aux poulains l'essence
même des restaurants encore plus des
bars et à la buvette chez simone
l'essence même
c'est la proximité tout est réfléchi à
la buvette pour le rapprochement les
tables les plateaux le port si le
rapprochement
je veux dire je sais pas pour vous mais
de voir verre de vin dans un cubicule un
lexique l'a servi par quelqu'un que des
gants et un masque en tout cas pour moi
c'est plus du film d'horreur mesdames
cheveux longs on doit s'arrêter
je vous souhaite bonne chance le message
est lancé merci bien
l'inertie merci